foreign
[Music]
thank you for taking the time to to
listen to my talk today uh my name is
Bailey zworage and I am currently the
associate director of scientific
business development at Altus biosystems
um I've been with Altis for almost five
years now
um and I'm in kind of a unique position
to have had a lot of
epithelial expertise and I brought that
to Altus on the scientific side and
moving more towards business development
now I've really been able to bridge the
gap between what we've done and what we
can do
and so today I'm really excited to talk
with you about
um using uh um an intestinal epithelial
in vitro model to predict pre-clinical
GI safety
so my bread and butter like I said is
the intestine um I talk a lot about it
and so I'm excited to talk with you
about it today uh we owe that the GI
tract is one of the major organs in your
body and the schematic on the left shows
kind of from top to bottom so it starts
in your mouth hits a lot of different
organs and then it comes out the end uh
where we have a lot of nutrient
absorption and water absorption and so
that end piece is the one we'll talk
about uh most specifically today
um and it's the colon and it's really
designed for water and electrolyte
absorption
the image on the right shows you the
regions of the large intestine so you
have it kind of goes up over and down in
the ascending transverse and descending
regions
um and if you're in the schematic right
in the middle you see that there's lots
of bumps in the colon and these are
called Hofstra and they're really for
um increasing surface area to churn all
the luminal contents to get all the
water and the nutrients out before it's
expelled from the body
and in the bottom right of this image it
shows you a cross section of the wall of
the gut and you can see it has a lot of
layers but the one that I'm always most
excited about is the innermost layer
which is the mucosa and all those little
cells on the on the very top of that are
the epithelium and they're what I've
studied for a majority of my research I
mean they're called the epithelium and
you see that they make this a crypt
structure um that kind of weaves in and
out of the mucosa to really increase the
surface area so we get a lot of the
water and the electrolytes out if we
zoom in on this epithelial layer we see
it kind of popped out here in the in the
image on the right but uh this focuses
on this epithelial layer and this is
important because it's the first line of
defense to everything that you find in
the Lumen of your gut and this includes
food microbiota Pharmaceuticals and
toxins
and so the end image shows you a
schematic of what those epithelial cells
look like they're a single cell layer
and you can see at the bottom we have
what's called lgr5 positive stem cells
and these are the true stem cells in the
gut
um and then uh the epithelium in that
Crypt structure kind of acts like an
escalator or an elevator the cells are
born at the bottom and then they migrate
up so we have these proliferating
Transit amplifying cells and then the
differentiated cells towards the top but
to help with the Regeneration of this
epithelial layer we're really focused
um on proliferative cells include those
stem cells at the very bottom that are
going to divide about every 24 hours or
so which give rise to um either more of
those stem cells or these Transit
amplifying proliferative cells now these
guys are going to divide three or four
times as they move up and out of the
crypt to those fully differentiated
cells that are responsible for mucous
production or absorption
now these guys are really important
because they are essential for all the
homeostatic regeneration
um and as well as any response to damage
and deal that can happen in a lot of
ways and the list here on the bottom
left is not mutually exclusive uh things
like disease can cause microbial
dysbiosis and inflammation and all of
that can lead to toxicity just like
inflammation can cause disease
um and so there's a lot of different
ways that gut can be damaged but at the
end of the day we're looking at what is
causing these cells to die and be
aberrant and what can we do about the
stem cells to make sure that our gut is
functioning properly
so this toxicity of the GI tract is a
really common side effect of a lot of
different drugs so the image right right
uh does show a lot of Adverse Events
that happen when we're taking
pharmaceutical drugs
um and these GI toxicities or gits is
what I'll call them is the most common
so that's at the very top of that list
now a lot of people have been trying to
figure out how do we best predict these
GI toxicities um prior to going into
clinical trials and um a group headed by
Matt Peters at AstraZeneca uh outlined
um a bunch of drugs
um they're they're 32 marketed drugs
um for any in vitro assay and these are
related towards drug safety these drugs
were chosen because they have a lot of
clinical in Vivo data that we can
compare to see how predictive our in
vitro models and this test set has been
used um by this group as well as others
uh to validate our in vitro models
I also wanted to point out that this was
also this paper as well as a paper
written by this next group was reviewed
by the iqmps consortia which is a really
a really great group of Industry leaders
who are working on in vitro MPS models I
have also looked at utilizing the same
test set for their in vitro models of GI
safety assessment
so when we're talking about in vitro
models there's a lot of different ones
that we can um you know talk about and
are used in the field the image on the
right hand side shows kind of the four
major buckets that these fall into uh in
a we have 2D transwells These are nice
because we can add cells to the top or
the bottom of the trans wells in B we
have a schematic of membrane-based
microfluidics so here this is a small
chip that we can add flow and stretch
and this come we really complicates the
environment
um and adds more physiologic relevance
to that
in C we have a traditional major drill
droplet culture so these guys are
embedded in this major gel Matrix um and
these are easy to passage and used in a
lot of labs and finally D is kind of
like the Cadillac of in vitra models
where we have uh really these Advanced
3D cultures where we can add tubes and
flow and different cell types to really
mimic what we're seeing in Vivo and so
with all of these different models
available
um we started to think about what um why
are our current in vitro models failing
why are we not able to predict this GI
toxicity before we go into the clinic
so some of these models are not
recapitulating their human biology so
some of them use non-human models or
immortalized cell lines
um and they don't really specifically
focus on those important uh
proliferative uh um stem and progenitor
cells
sometimes the results are not
reproducible uh maybe when we're using a
cell line for study number one we'll use
passage two but when we run study number
10 we're using passage 22 and our
changes happening in those cells and are
they important is a question that I
think we often don't think about
uh the cultures uh and some of these
platforms are relatively low throughput
um so with them being
um kind of cumbersome or long to use
this could limit maybe the number of
compounds a group tests maybe the doses
or the replicates and so we can be
missing that with uh not having enough
power in the studies that we're doing
and finally these assays don't always
come with consultation or expert
experience when we're running the models
and so
um this could lead to you know using the
models incorrectly or having some other
problems uh so what we just we did here
at Altus is we um have developed um a 2d
trans wall system and so that's what
we're going to be talking about today
so our current model current culture
model that we use is called replica
planer and what we have here on the left
is a cross-section of one of those
transwells and so we utilize just the
upper compartment to put the cells in
and you see them there in green and
yellow we have a nice differentiated
monolayer and we're utilizing this trans
well which we really like because in the
light pink we have our luminal Reservoir
and in that dark pink we have a basal
Reservoir so this gives us really nice
access to both the top and the bottom of
the cells
and when we culture ourselves on these
trans walls we have about a 10-day
culture period where the first
approximately four days half the culture
we have lots of cell expansion so those
proliferative cells are present here and
in the second half we have
differentiation where we actually have a
nice barrier
and showing you some data that we have
we do have these proliferative cells
that we can mark with the functional
marker edu and on the differentiated
side we have the major cells that we
would see in Vivo including absorptive
enterocytes goblet cells and
intrendocrine cells and we really like
this model because if we want to assay
proliferative cells we can use the
beginning of our platform and if we're
more interested in asking differentiated
cells we can wait towards the end and
run the assays then
so because we're talking about toxicity
and we're focused on proliferative cells
we're just going to take this first part
of the culture which we have done at
Altus and only and named that specific
culture system um stem screen
now on this timeline here on the left we
see it's just the initial blue part for
that cell expansion phase and on Day
Zero is when we plate the cells and once
once they sit down and become happy
they're about 50 confluent on day two
they'll become more and more confluent
so when they're about 75 to 80 percent
is when we're going to give them
compounds and then we're going to allow
them to grow for another two days and
we'll be able to fix them and see if
they formed a barrier
and what we get out of this assay system
is three Downstream analyzes the first
is barrier function but oh that will
measure by tier the second is getting
total cell number left after the assay
which we can do by uh quantifying gappy
staining and finally we'll get
proliferative cell number by looking at
EDU
so first looking at the tier this helps
us answer the question of are the cells
able to form a confluent monolayer in
response to compound treatment so the
way we measure tier or trans epithelial
electrical resistance is by using a
probe one of them is shown here on the
left in our 96 oil plates and in the
right this is an example of what those
cells look like after we switch them to
our differentiation medium you see the
tier starts low and increases over time
so really any register of this tier is
showing that these cells are forming a
barrier
we can also look at total cell number so
this helps us answer the question of
what is the viability or the total
number of cells left in response to
compound treatment
so the way we do this is on the very
bottom we can use high throughput image
analysis using open source software
called cell profiler
the bottom left image the black and
white one is what the image that we get
off of the microscope the image in the
middle has green dots in all of those
cells and this is how the imaging
software is able to
quantify those cells and on the right is
what I like to call a confetti plot
which is going to just randomly color
the cells uh the cell nuclei so you can
generally see how many cells are left
and
uh intercalation to quantify
proliferative cell number and here we
can answer the question of how many
cells contain edu or were they did they
actively uptake that edu or were they
born during the time they were given edu
in response to cytokine or compound
treatment
the way we do edu analysis um you can
see on the top schematic we add the edu
to the cell culture edu is a thymidine
analog so as these cells are dividing
it's going to intercalate into the DNA
just like thymidine would and you can
see in the middle image there is a
little tag on it and once we fix the
cells and we're going to analyze them we
run what's called a click it reaction
and you can see on the Right image that
it adds a little fluorophore so we can
see
um if this cell did uptake this edu
during the time so this is how we can
quantify this using the same bottom
image analysis for a different color
Channel
um all the all those cells that are edu
positive
so back to our study design uh what we
did is we have this very large compound
test set
um I will not be going through all of
these compounds I will just pull a
couple of them that I've highlighted
here with the arrows but you can see we
have a long list of toxic compounds by
Peter's group uh with varying incidences
of clinical diarrhea from 40 to 96 and
then we also have an even larger set of
non-toxic compounds so these are
compounds that have proven to not have
gi toxicity uh that we're looking to
make sure in our in future models are
not causing any off-target effects
so getting into the data analyzes and
the results
the first uh compound that we looked at
is called Ida rubison and you can see on
the top we have a pretty high GI toxins
now Ida rubicin is going to inhibit
topraisomerase II and it can bind to DNA
and in the clinic we're using it to
treat breast cancer lymphoma leukemia
and and it can help reduce cardiac
toxicity
so what we first did here is we did we
looked at the edu so these are all the
cells that intercalated that EDU
the left part of this first image is the
vehicle so this is our 100 this is what
we would expect to see and you can see
as we move to the right from that
vehicle we have less and less of those
edu positive cells and this is
suggesting that the E that this compound
Ida rubison is causing less and less of
these cells to proliferate
we can quantify this so this image on
the bottom this figure here shows two
different donors our donor 5 and our
donor one with the same compound and you
see that as we increase the
concentration which is on our x-axis
we're having less and less of these edu
positive cells
we can also look at total cells so here
on the bottom uh this image is called
the quantification of the total number
of cells so you can see that it actually
takes a higher dose of this either
rubison to start causing decreases in
the total cell number so these bottom
two image bottom two images on the
bottom right are showing less of those
cells in general present
and we can quantify this as well
so what we see here on this top right
graph uh is we're we're plotting both
the dappy or the total number of cells
which is the red line and then the
proliferative cells which we just talked
about which is this green line
now we can subtract one from the other
to get the total number of
non-proliferative cells and what I think
is interesting here is you see that at
this specific dose range and the
highlighted by the green box we do see a
decrease
um in the number of proliferative cells
at a higher concentrate at a lower
concentration excuse me than uh affected
the the total cells in general and so
this is saying that we're having a cell
dependent response to the Ida rubison
we can also look at what concentrations
of this compound caused a barrier
function defects so remember here what
we're doing is saying are these cells
making a barrier at the end of the assay
and you can see where we've highlighted
the cmax on the dotted line in this
bottom graph that the normalized here
does start to drop and at 10 to the
negative Sixth and higher we actually
have do not have barrier function and
this is very indicative of when the
total cell number is decreasing in the
top graph
so from this data we can conclude that
Ida ribosin causes a dose and cell type
dependent toxic response in these cells
the next compound we'll look at is
called colchicine and this causes
tubulin disruption that leads to the
down regulation of inflammatory Pathways
so we use this compound to treat gout
pericarditis and can it can help reduce
the risk of cardiovascular events
now here we're looking again at total
cell number so the top rate graph in
Gray is our total cell number again in
green are our proliferative cells and in
purple are the non-proliferative cells
so what's interesting about this is that
at 10 to the negative 6 we see a drop in
the number of proliferative cells
however we're not seeing any changes in
the non-proliferative cell population
this is indicative when we look at the
cells themselves so we see that the blue
images on the top are our dappy staining
and at these higher concentrations we
still have some cells left so the top
right image there are blue blue cells
left but there are no green edu positive
cells in this bottom right image
and when we look at here on those
proliferative cells we're seeing that as
we lose the proliferative cell capacity
in the top graph we're losing the T
ability for the cells to form a barrier
in the bottom so you see that 10 to the
negative 6 uh on the bottom graph is
where we don't have barrier function now
interestingly in this set of data we
also ran a colchicine on just fully
differentiated cells so these are a full
barrier there are no proliferative cells
and you see that there's no change in
the ability for this these cell these
cells to maintain a barrier when given
colchicine
so from both of these data sets we can
conclude that colchicine selectively
targets proliferative cells to reduce
the cell number and this is what the
mechanism of action is as culture seeing
target cells that are in metaphase
we next looked at fortezamik which has
about a 50 GI incidence now bortezidine
is going to reversibly bind to the cytok
chymotrypsin subunit of the 26s
proteosome and we use it in the clinic
to treat multiple Myoma and mantle cell
life lipoma
um and what you see here is again on the
top right our total cell number
proliferative cell number and
non-proliferative cell number and this
is different from our previous slide
where once we hit that 10 to the
negative 7 molar drug dose we have no
cells left
this is very indicative when we look at
the cells themselves so in this bottom
image of the cells no blue and no green
when we're looking at the compounds
treated with these high doses of
portasamin
um and when we look at the cells um uh
ability to form barriers we do see that
both in the proliferative and
differentiated cells
um we are do not have the ability to
form a barrier at about this 10 to the
negative 7 10 to the negative six uh um
concentration and we do have the C-Max
pointed out here showing that our
platform is a little more sensitive than
the C-Max that we would see in the
clinic
so here we can conclude that portism
non-selectively reduces the number of
cells regardless of proliferative status
and this makes sense with its mechanism
of action because it's going to Target
all metabolically active cells so it
doesn't matter if they are proliferative
or not
the last two compounds that I have to
discuss are a fat nib and Verapamil so a
fat nib is an egfr inhibitor you can see
it has the highest incidence of GI talks
from our list and when we look at um
what it does to our in vitro cultures is
it very reproducibly decreases the
number of edu cells so we're decreasing
proliferation in a dose-dependent manner
now what I like to highlight from this
data set is this is done on two
different donors so donor one and donor
five and this was actually run on more
than 10 plates so this is a at least an
N of 30 uh for each of these
um each of these points that we're
seeing here and we're seeing this nice
reproducible decrease with the effect
nymph
now Verapamil
um we've talked a lot about compounds
that decrease and are toxic to our
monolayers however Rock Mill is one on
the list that uh should be non-toxic and
so here Verapamil is a calcium channel
blocker an anti-hypertensive drug with a
very low GI tox incidence and when we
overlap this data we see that there is
no change in the proliferative cell
count um in among both of these donors
so again this was done on more than 10
plates per donor and I think that this
really highlights that these two
compounds are nice positive and negative
controls for our study
so just to summarize all the compounds
that we talked about
um we put put together a little graph uh
so these are the compounds on the left
hand side with their diarrhea
incidencies or GI talks and the clinical
C-Max that we're seeing in the clinic
our stem screen platform uh we went to
that tier data so the barrier formation
data and developed ic15s now if you're
in you if you're familiar with talks
you're familiar with ic50s however the
Peter's paper used ic15
their data so if we look on the right
hand side how we calculated these ic15s
is where we saw about a change 18 off of
um than the the vehicles uh so that
would be that blue dotted line right
here so you can see in the the table to
the left the stem screen tier ic50s were
similar to the clinical c-maxes I mean
if anything they were more sensitive
finding toxicities at lower doses than
the clinical cmaps
now in this Peter's paper uh they were
looking at two other platforms Keiko 2
cells as well as map text cells now you
can see here these were their tier ic15s
and when we look at a compound like
bortezumib remember that didn't uh
didn't matter what kind of cells were
there proliferative or non-proliferative
they were toxic and because they cake O2
cells and the matex cells have these
metabolically active cells all three
platforms were able to uh predict that
clinical C-Max and were very similar
however when we look at a compound like
colchicine that's very specific to those
proliferative cells you see the stem
screen model predicted the clinical
C-Max better than the Keiko 2 and the
mat text which were false negatives
these two platforms do not have a
majority of proliferative cells and
because of that perhaps became false
negatives in this study
uh and so the Peter's uh Peters group
Define true positives as within an 80
fold of the C-Max and so those are
highlighted here in the
um in the black and then the false
negatives were greater than 80 fold off
of the C-Max and so you can see those I
highlighted in red
so in conclusion I think I showed you
today that the monolayer platform that
we're using can help protect predict GI
safety
um I think that there's a lot of
clinical relevance from this platform we
are using primary human epithelial cells
and this helps to recapitulate that in
vivophysiology we're actually using the
cells isolated directly from organ
donors
and the toxic concentrations that we
found in our in vitro model well aligned
with clinical C-Max values and this was
using a test Set uh that was unbiased
and really well received in the field
the results that we that I showed here
are very high value I think it's
important that a platform can answer
does this kill the cells we want kind of
more than that out of a platform and so
the three deliverables that we identify
do help to identify the mechanism and
the function so looking at uh does this
compound cause defects and barrier
formation and total and proliferative
cell number
and finally this model is high
throughput so it does have a short four
day cell culture timeline the two other
platforms that I talked about have
longer culture timelines so caco2s need
to grow for 21 days before you can assay
them and then map text platform does
take two to four weeks to differentiate
and be ready to treat and this platform
is also in a 96 wall plate format so it
is amendable to high throughput Imaging
and analyzes
the future directions for this assay and
kind of this r d initiative are to
investigate more cells in altus's
biobank so um Altus does have a cell
biobank that allows for us to look at
donor diversity so we do have multiple
donors available to us as well as more
GI regions
um we're very aware that toxicity can
potentially be focal to specific tissues
based on the mechanism of the drugs so
are we seeing differences in the small
intestine versus the colon we actually
have all six regions of the gut from
each of our donors so we are able to
test does something look different in
the duodenum versus the descending colon
and those are questions we're excited to
answer
we also want to look at other toxicity
related readouts there's a lot of
interest especially at the GMP level
looking at genetic toxicity
um I think we can easily look at things
like gene expression what is changing at
the gene level and also the protein
level which we can do by immunostining
and looking at secreted proteins
and finally we would like to investigate
the long-term epithelial remodeling so
we add the compounds that this blue in
the blue phase right where those cells
are expanding but what happens if we let
them grow and we let them keep growing
if they aren't toxic are we causing
changes in differentiation are we
causing changes in barrier function or
what's secreted by those specific cells
so we're excited to investigate all of
these things
so I really want to thank everyone for
their time and focus during my talk
um I just really wanted to end with
letting everyone know that we do have a
research funding opportunity
um it is up to ten thousand dollars with
our current program Focus being
toxicology so a lot of what I talked
about today this submission due date is
relatively soon um and we do have an
online proposal submission and I added
the website here
um but if you are interested please
definitely let me know my email is at
the beginning of this talk
um and you can uh ask questions in the
ask a question box and those will be
sent directly to my email so I look
forward to hearing from everyone and
hope everyone has a great conference
um and thank you again